keep you up the r
feel feel
yes feel feel where you're stuck look
here see
you
try
turn you're here and it's going
forward wait watch it's going forward
you go here here your
pin your arm goes forward and you keep
moving and I go forward okay
one stay with me okay don't get pinned
here keep your Center moov and you come
forward don't pin yourself it's get it
gets pinned right so step with the other
leg then go under it
yes under it cuz if I go hard it's going
to bend you in
high so it's taking you
forward you just go under it yes and
down you go
forward yeah that's how easy it is
[Music]
no
yes reconcil it get
up get
up go under it take this pressure off
yes pressure off
yes move move move pressure off
okay so this
is a Mobility drill okay for
UK so when he goes okay
so have it on me okay I'm you know I'm
spinally
displacing okay and I'm not going from
my
shoulders on on to my
knees my my it's my feet where the
ground path is okay so because I'm here
and not
here when he Yin
yields I'm not going to fall like that
you see now you've pinned yourself and
then you
lost the connection element for
kiom so instead because I'm pushing for
my feet when he yields I can move you
see then he takes me off balance and
this is where your inside leg's going to
get pinned cuz that's what he's doing
he's pinning it so I'm here at this
point but he's not done with the
kazushi because he's got to get my
Center to go forward slow down please
okay right now if he throws if he goes
and throws he's going to bring back my
balance and then you're you're going to
get him okay so he's not going to go
forward his hand's going to go this way
and he's going to spin my head around
but I'm
pinned so it's the outside foot that
goes outside foot that goes and how far
should it
go as far but he also is trying to only
accomplish a certain thing so you're not
trying to send me another 180 around do
you understand you're trying to get my
shoulders to allow my Center to be
unpinned but not this knee so when he
goes around wait because you're not
sensitive you're going to feel it here
it is okay and now he's going to release
the shoulder there you go okay now
Energy's coming back got it right he's
throwing this way but I was going
forward so when he goes here
I'm
here not going to go like
this pin come back go just go back and I
go like
[Music]
this I'm
feeling the
connection
around you can do the Thro
right who
around you can see that his arm is like
passing me can you
see you see that okay try
it okay so I'm going to pin this leg
right there you see so right there is
where that leg is pinned this is where I
transfer to to the head I transfer to
the head you see and now I bring his
Center forward and you can see like the
the grip it does come off at this point
and that's why I trade adhesion points
okay and so the
UK you should just if if your grip is
making you pinned you let go of the grip
okay and now I'm on the head and you're
going to feel like if I go here you're
never going to come up so I'm going to
get your Center to go up you see okay
and then he's falling from that move and
I stay with
him I'm not throwing him down do you
feel
that so again I can't go too far cuz
that I over pinned the leg and he can't
take that step and stay with
me I I'm feeling what's happening to his
body the leg got ped in I now go to the
head I bring the center around you need
to come more forward dude there you go
cuz you cuz you don't want to take off
that pressure you don't want to be
popped in the
face that's what you're trying to do so
around and underneath it and I stay with
him
yes go it when it's not serving
you it can't be small you see it same
exact thing
okay try it again as he's doing the
technique everyone's Mobility is a
little different but the Tactical
components remain the same so somebody
who's Less Mobile they'll be checked out
with less on that front leg do you see
you don't want to have in your head that
my coku hole always does 270°
do you get it you're looking for the leg
check on the inside when you feel it and
that's when you transition to the Head
contact you leave the grip alone okay
you're not really concerned with the
grip you go to here okay and then your
only goal how far do I do on my uh on my
gashi there it's going to be only to get
their Center to come forward do do you
understand that don't you're not trying
to have a form you're trying to have an
energetic feeling
okay so I push there it is W com around
and again you're going to keep cont set
you get it okay here's where we should
end
up again boom 10 boom that's
it you you had me pinned a little bit
and I got heavy on you right
there you
go good
[Music]
hey try it
again so on the suaza techniques you're
you just work on the gasi part okay so
I'm coming around and I just want to
work on that part
okay um just like if I'm doing Eda we
know that it's a homolateral throw but
in suar Wasa it's not right he throws
across my
body
okay if I if I'm doing that that
technique right it's going to be a
homolateral throw right
there oh same way with K hold the legs
going to come in
but it's this far to
same right too many of us go like this
on the
standing you're working on this
part is what you're working on in this
what you're working on and this what
was hey here it
is I just call that like Kash you make
that
Circle you're doing it on his head
that's the part you're working on right
there move his Center fre it
okay try